if you were to think of a seite level
fighter Dana White is is pretty well the
crap yeah you've you've spent a good bit
of time sort of orbiting that that whole
crew of people what have you learned
from your insights about the UFC and and
sort of what that says about Dana oh
listen what I'm about to say about Dana
is some people are not going to like it
but I'm I'm going to say it anyways UFC
is what UFC is because of Dana White you
can sit there and talk about all these
Fighters and yeah but you know if it
wasn't for this guy if it wasn't for
that guy if it wasn't for what this
person did and that totally get it
listen different players come and go
right totally
understand uh Dana has made it about the
sport he never made it about the fight
uh he never made it about one fighter he
is very quick to call out anybody it
doesn't matter if it's the number one
guy in the leag he'll call him out Jon
Jones he'll call out Conor if he screws
up but he'll back him up to the highest
level he'll say that was some stupid
he did he'll sit there and straight
up tell you what he likes what he
doesn't like but everybody learned
during coid he was the number one
commissioner in all of sports every
commissioner in America caved NBA caved
NFL caved MLB caved every commissioner
caved except for one guy who had brass
boss called Dana White who said I don't
give a we're going to find a place
to do the fight so during coid you know
what's the only sport the world watched
we watched UFC no one's watching a
freaking football game with no fans out
there cardboards what am I going to do
with cardboards oh no we're going to
watch hey you can buy this seat for your
face to be on the you know basketball
game who gives a it was the most
boring Finals Lakers won ever they
shouldn't even deserve to have won that
final there was no audience nobody
booing against you but everybody
realized here's Dana as a commissioner
then it's everybody else you're not at
his level he's a wartime uh leader as
well as a peace time leader
he's learned how to pres moving together
he said something in an interview he
says listen man maybe it's just the fact
that I'm getting old and I'm getting
soft but I have a hard time seeing
what's going on with some of these guys
and you know in the way his personal
life when he went through that crisis
and the way he put it he says you want
me to be embarrassed how much more
embarrassed you want me to be you know
how embarrassing it is to talk to my
wife and my kids you know how
embarrassing that is this is nothing
compared to how embarrassing to have to
face my
kids you respect that you love that
there's a degree of it especially to
Dana that is very rare and I think that
one of the things the UFC's done is make
boxing particularly feel so Antiquated
and pedestrian and the fact that KSI
almost be Tommy Fury you know how bad
that would have been for boxing that's
not good that's not good but he KSI does
not represent UFC either uh he doesn't
but what would have happened if a
YouTuber would have beaten a
professional boxer with a last name of
Fury it's humiliating correct many
people would have said he could have won
on the points but what was it that you
said you made some comparison about
jockey and horses to do with Dana
White yes I made the analysis with Elon
Musk where you had the bet on the the
same goes with Dana White as well though
yeah so you got the jockey and the horse
okay you got Dana White is the Jackie
the horses UFC Elon Musk is a Jackie
Tesla is the horse okay so if tomorrow
Elon Musk resigned from Tesla to only do
Twitter what happens to
Tesla it's going to be disturbing for a
lot of investors because a lot of people
bought Tesla because it's Elon Musk a
lot of people are selling Tesla and
getting rid of their cars like AOC it's
Elon Musk ever since he bought Twitter
double EDG sword yeah it's a double
edged sword but you know to me in a
perfect world is if you can have both I
think UFC is a great product phenomenal
product addicting product okay viral
product uh but Dana White is an
incredible Jackie do you remember
someone brought up I think it was Israel
adna who had been using the nword and
it's at the press conference I mean it
must be fun for the Press you know to
sit down and Dana sits down he goes all
right guys what's going on the gate
tonight was we broke this he the fight
of the nights and then he just looks up
and someone asks him a question and he
just says what he thinks you know he
doesn't say something that the media
team has prepped him on although I'm
sure he's got training and he
understands the boundaries but nothing
feels
prescribed uh
manufactured conceited uh nothing
contrived nothing feels like that it
just feels like this is what the guy
thinks uh someone I I saw this on the
internet someone had talked
about many organizations and YouTubers
at the moment are trying to speedrun
authenticity
right they're trying to growth hack
relatability how can I make myself seem
more authentic and relatable than I
actually am obviously it's kind of a
self-defeating prophecy which is that
the only way to be authentic is to be
authentic and there's a degree of trust
you know I mean Dana dude the start of
this year was rough for him that him and
his Ms got into a scuffle and it got
videoed and it was maybe like New Year's
Eve or something like oh January 1st
guess I was starting 2023 the worst way
possible and he comes out and you have
faith that you go yeah this guy meant
what he said there I don't think that
there's any demons looking in the closet
because I may regret saying that at some
point in future but I don't think that
I'm going to need to because I just have
faith that I'm not Dana White I don't
have stock in Dana White I just I'm a
good judge of character and I see in him
someone that seems to tell the truth
more often than not and seems to be very
open and honest and own his mistakes and
people love that people really really
like that so yeah it makes him
incredibly likable ath authenticity at
the highest level that brand is a very
authentic brand he he's had his you know
his enemies he's had the people that
have challenged him and given him a hard
time but Dana in in a past life could
have been a gangster maybe he was but he
could have been a gangster he could have
ran a family that's how Dana is he could
have been he Dana is almost not a mob
boss you know of a Gambino family or
geneves or Columbo Dana's more the guy
that ran the commission like a luchano
that's Dana and to be that
guy there is no book you can read to be
that you can read 40 lot of power 100
times you can't be that guy you either
are that guy you're not that guy big
boss energy Dana is that guy Dana is
that guy we'll get back to talking to
Patrick in one minute but first I need
to tell you about Shopify Shopify is the
e-commerce platform revolutionizing
businesses all over the world whether
you're a garage entrepreneur or IPO
ready Shopify is the only tool that you
need to start run and grow your business
online without the hassle Shopify Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States and if they are good enough for
huge Brands like gym shark they are good
enough for you too Shopify puts you in
control of every sales channel so
whether you're selling satin sheets from
shopify's in-person POS system or
offering organic olive oil on shopify's
all-in-one e-commerce platform they've
got you covered and once you've reached
your audience Shopify has the internet's
best converting checkout to help you
turn brows into buyers if you are
someone who is looking to start a
business online Shopify is the only
place to go they are a One-Stop shop to
create your business so if you are
looking to take your business to the
next level you can sign up for a $1 per
month trial period right now by going to
the link in the description below or
heading to shopify.com
sodern wisdom in all lowercase that's
shopify.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Patrick then press here for the ful
length over 2hour long podcast go on
give it a
press